-♪ "Tonight Show Dance Battle,"
yeah ♪
-Now, here is
the Dance Move Generator.
You're gonna take turns
hitting this button,
which will randomly select
a never-before-seen dance move.
Whoever's turn it is has to
make up a dance for that move,
and the best dancer wins.
Finn, since you're the closest,
why don't you go first?
Let's just start
the Dance Move Generator.
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
I feel like yours is gonna be
a performance piece.
[ Laughter ]
-It's gonna be like birds.
-Yeah, okay, yeah, birds.
[ Beeps ]
[ Laughter ]
-Toastin' Waffles.
-Toast -- Toast --
Oh, it does say --
Toasty Waffles --
-[ Chuckling ] What?
-Toastin' Waffles.
-Toast and waffles.
-Toast --
-You want to do toast
and waffles?
-Like you're toasting them.
-It's the same thing.
-Okay, good. All right.
So this is --
Finn is doing Toastin' Waffles.
Roots, can he get a beat?
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Finale plays ]
Wow, fantastic.
Very performance artist.
[ Laughs ]
As he walked out...
-Whoo!
-Very -- That's how you make
toast and waffles
in the morning?
[ Laughter ]
I just love that you --
I like that you yawned,
climbed out of bed,
and there was like two
thawed-out waffles on your...
-There was two waffles.
-Already there.
-"I put them out last night."
-Did he toast them?
I just saw him, like,
do the "Macarena."
-Yeah,
he was doing the "Macarena,"
then he ate a sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go.
It's Gaten's turn.
Let's start
the Dance Move Generator.
[ Beeping ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
[ Beeps ]
-Flashlight
With A Mind Of Its Own.
-[ Laughing ] What?
-How do you do that?
-So, Flashlight
With A Mind Of Its Own.
Gaten.
Roots, give him a beat.
-1, 2!
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Finale plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
That was awesome!
Fantastic!
-Yes, that was so good.
-That is fantastic!
Oh, now -- now the game --
They're --
Everyone's upping their game.
Noah, try and top that.
-I'm worried.
-Let's start the Generator here.
[ Beeping ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
[ Laughter ]
-When do I press it?
-Whenever you're ready.
I mean, you can let this go
for 25 minutes if you want to.
I mean,
it's getting a little annoying.
[ Beeping continues ]
[ Beeps ]
Trying To Fix An '80s TV.
-'80s TV.
-Do you know what a television
looked like in the '80s?
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ]
This is so sad.
-It was, like, boxy.
-Yeah, so, it was boxy, yeah.
-You remember --
like, on set -- on set.
-It was a big box,
and it was, like, wooden,
and it had two switches.
-Yeah, exactly like that.
-It was wider than that.
-Exactly like that.
-Like that.
-To fix it,
you'd have to either bang on it
or put a screwdriver in it...
-Okay.
-...or something like that.
-Yeah.
And they had channels
that you could turn,
and that's how you'd know
that it was broken.
Okay.
-I -- All right.
-This is so sad.
I really feel old.
[ Laughter ]
Welcome back to Grandpa's
"Tonight Show," everybody.
[ Laughter ]
Trying To Fix An '80s TV.
All right, here's Noah --
Roots!
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Stop! Hey, hey!
That's -- My TV's -- Hey!
[ Finale plays ]
Get up. Noah!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-You just --
It's not plugged in.
It's just not plugged in.
That's all you got to do.
Just plug it in.
Get out of here.
-That's it?!
-Get out of here.
That's all you got to do
is plug the thing in.
-What? It wasn't plugged in
the whole time.
-It was unplugged.
Caleb.
-Classic rookie mistake.
-Caleb, let's see
if you can top that, okay?
Let's start
the Dance Move Generator.
-Okay.
[ Beeping ]
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
[ Beeps ]
-That did not work out.
-There you go.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
I was trying to be cool.
-No, it's all right.
No, it's all right.
Breaking Through The Goo.
That's The Upside Down --
that little, like, portal thing.
That gloppy --
-Oh!
-The sticky, sticky stuff.
-Remember -- the show?
-Oh. Oh!
-Like the little gate thing.
-Oh, yeah.
-You got this.
-Yeah, the show.
-The show on Netflix.
-"Stranger Things."
-Breaking Through The Goo.
Roots!
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Finale plays ]
-[ Laughs ]
There you are.
[ Laughs ]
-Oh.
-That was actually a good --
he messed it all around, see?
-Oh.
-Now -- Now you're rethinking
Toastin' Waffles.
Yeah, I know what's up.
[ Laughter ]
All right, now, listen --
listen, you guys.
Come on down here.
Caleb, Noah, Gaten, Finn,
you're all clearly amazing
[British accent] dancers.
-What? Dancers?
-[ British accent ] Dancers.
-Why even compete
against each other
when we can do
one more dance together?
-One more?
-Together.
-Together?
-Let's do this.
-[ Normal voice ] Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm gonna join you.
I want to join you
for the last dance.
-Let's do it!
-I actually have an idea
for this one.
This is called
"The Upside Get Down."
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's --
Roots, can I have some, like,
a little music
so I can talk to the guys
for a second?
[ Drum roll ]
-You -- It's --
-Huddle, huddle, huddle, huddle.
-Huddle, huddle, huddle up.
-Huddle.
-Maybe, we'll do -- we'll do --
like, move our feet
like that first.
-Yeah, this.
-"The Breakfast Club."
-Bass guitar.
-And then
we'll do the bass guitar.
-Yes, yes, yes. Okay.
-Ah, okay.
♪♪
-Which way? Which way?
-I don't know.
-That way first.
-This way.
-All right, ready, Roots?
Give us --
Oh, forgot the best part.
♪♪
-Wait, which way do we...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Ready?
-1, 2!
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That's all the time we have
for "Tonight Show Dance Battle."
My thanks
to Finn, Gaten, Noah, Caleb!
Season 2 of "Stranger Things"
is available now on Netflix.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with World Series Champion
José Altuve!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪